welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and this video we're
breaking down deadbeat dad the movie
starring george clooney the midnight sky
has quite a symbolic ending and
a lot to unpack from it and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down
whilst giving our interpretation of it
based on the book
good morning midnight by lily brooks
dalton it tells the story of a man
filled with regret trying to do one last
good deed
before he slips off this mortal coil
we're going to be going over it all but
if this is your first time here then
please subscribe to the channel
and make sure you click the thumbs up
button if you enjoy the video
come on yeah it is christmas now now we
start off in 2049
three weeks after a cataclysmic event
that has completely ruined earth's
atmosphere
because god cupcaked the planet those
that could escape decided to leave and
journey into space
in the hopes of finding a new home
rather than following them though we
stay behind with a terminally ill
scientist called augustine
played by george clooney i know i'm not
really selling the movie yet but but
trust me it gets better
look it's got santa in it now at an
arctic base we see as
augustine tries to reach out to the
passengers of the ether
a ship making a return journey from
jupiter moon k23
which is capable of housing human life
either actually means the air that the
ancient greeks believe was breed them by
the olympians
and they are very much seen as being
above the earth looking down on us
and living in somewhat of a paradise
there's also many biblical references
such as adam and eve
noah's ark and so on but we'll get into
this more towards the end of the video
now initially it seems like augustine is
joined by a young mute girl
who is left behind by her mother at the
start of the movie
though this could be setting up the plot
of the home alone reboot it's actually
revealed to be a hallucination
and this girl is a stand-in for his true
daughter who is aboard the ether
depending on how early you guess
this twist probably determines how much
you will enjoy the movie
and i have to say that the first half
hour felt rather dull and slow
but things do pick up as we watch the
trials and tribulations that both sides
of the story go through
at its heart the midnight sky is about
augustine analyzing what he should have
focused on in his life
namely his daughter and it's actually
quite sad seeing the character living
out his last days
wishing he'd done things differently
when augustine was a younger man
he threw himself into his work at the
expense of others
and ruined his relationship with his
partner and daughter because of his
fascination with k23
augustine unfortunately was someone who
spent his entire time trying to get away
from those close to
him and this is why he focused on the
moon instead of making true connections
his goal the one thing driving him was
to journey there
but we know from what we see in the
character that it would have been as
empty for him
as the life he had on earth he was
someone who shut out others
and clearly he didn't want a family
possibly because he thought they would
either be a distraction
or something that would slow him down
from his goals now this drive is
actually something that helps the
character make a perilous journey across
the arctic in order to reach a better
functioning satellite base
and it's clear that in the end he wishes
to make a connection with someone
he's just lucky enough to make contact
with his own daughter
and there are several characters that
are the complete opposite to him
i think augustine is very well
juxtaposed by mitchell
who wants to return to earth even after
learning that it's been completely
decimated
throughout the film we see him as
someone who is kept away from his family
because of his work
and he wants to do nothing more than to
get back to them
this is of course a polar opposite to
augustine who viewed his family as
something that kept him away from his
work
i think the two characters work really
well in reflecting each other
sanchez who too returns to earth
discusses with mitchell about how time
is used
and how to make one's lifetime mean
something he divulges that his daughter
died
and also talks about how he dreams that
his child and mitchells were friends
he wants to use his time to help his
buddy the one person that's been there
for him
and shows that we can all find meaning
in life and make it count
now in opposite to this there's a really
heartbreaking scene in which we see
august reminiscing over his partner
telling him that she wasn't pregnant
clearly this was a lie that she told to
him
because she realized where his
priorities lay augustine couldn't pull
himself away from his work to even
answer the phone to speak to her
and thus we see that he's willing to let
everything go so that he can focus on
his obsession
his partner wouldn't even tell their
daughter that he was her dad
because he knew that he would resent her
for it if there were obstacles that got
in the way
but i have to say i think augustine
actually resents himself more than
anything
when watching the film for a second time
i found the flashback moments the most
heartbreaking
and not even george clooney voice
dubbing over the actor's lines
put me off these moments i'm crying i
really showed someone who thought that
what he wanted had more value than what
he had
and he was willing to throw it all away
on the off chance that he could get
something better
on the other hand mitchell is willing to
go back to certain death
just to be with his wife and children
because he knows that they are what made
his life important
and that he wouldn't have anything if
they were gone augustine however
wished to spend his last few days dying
by himself in the cold
but clearly his subconscious had other
plans and thus had created this
apparition of his daughter iris
to at least give him some connection i
think this manifestation of here makes
him realize that
what he truly wants to do is gain a
connection to someone
anyone and nurse he sets out on his
final mission
to reach out to the ether this is shown
by him saying to iris that he wishes
she'd tell him anything about her life
and clearly he wants to know if there
was any point to his
now the movie does have a lot of tense
moments namely a sinking trailer in the
middle of the arctic
as well as debris fields that hid the
ether when people are outside making
repairs
just a bit of advice here never say that
it's your first and last space walk when
you're in the middle of it mate
you're just asking for trouble there now
these action scenes are great
but i think the film really comes
together in the end and it's more about
the emotional connections that are made
rather than the sinking feeling that you
get whilst watching the action scenes
play out
now in the end the real iris tells
augustine about k23
and how incredible it is he saw himself
as someone that just pointed to places
whilst others went there and doesn't
really feel like there was much value in
what he did
however iris completely negates this
idea when she talks about how amazing
what he did
in discovering the moon she says that
it's similar to colorado which is where
the two are both stationed at at one
point
and talks about the sky being orange as
well as the plant life and vegetation
as we know august was never able to go
there but this conversation allows him
and his mind to arrive at the place he
longed for the entire time
somewhere that his daughter will soon
call home with the apparition of her
they look over the midnight sky
which now has orange in it and he stares
at iris
knowing that he did something the
character passes away as we hear the
real one narrating her time on the moon
indicating as to what the future will be
like she states that she's never seen
something so beautiful
and in some ways this verifies that all
of augustine's work wasn't for nothing
there was purpose to it and rather than
dying completely with a feeling of
regret
he can look back on his life and know
that his daughter was able to take
something from it
augustine's goal this entire time was to
find a connection with someone
something to show that his work did mean
something and that the sacrifice of his
family
was worth it in the end he does find
this and through his daughter we can see
firsthand that though he has regrets
over the way he acted
that it wasn't all for nothing ling iris
also being open to the idea of naming
her child after another flower
also suggests that his legacy will carry
on through his grandchild
though he was never there for her in his
life his death
and the actions he took in the movie
saved his and he watches iris and add a
wallet
travel back to k23 now this credit scene
in which they sit at the control panel
brings a lot with it and clearly the
pair are going to be the adam and eve of
their new world
earth was a paradise at one point but
they've been cast out and now must
journey to a new home
and start out all over again god or
rather natural forces
wash the earth clean and with this arc
they'll travel to somewhere safe
in order to begin again might be
reaching there but
just how i took it now the pair stepping
away from the control panels is quite
somber
and there is really two ways that you
can take it you can see it as them
living a long life together
and restarting the human race or that
they might face the same difficulties
that augustine did
adewale did seem quite apprehensive over
learning that he was having a daughter
and in some ways i see him as a metaphor
for augustine
though the pair hold hands in the finale
they're distracted by a notification
and then they both return to their work
adewale steps away and leaves iris at
the panel with her unborn child
i kindly took this as symbolizing that
the mistakes of the past will be
repeated
they go away using different staircases
and who knows
they may end up being separated however
that doesn't mean it's for nothing
and humanity will return though we could
always be plagued by the same mistakes
that we've been victims of
i think there's a lot to take from it
and though i didn't really find
midnight sky all that amazing first
watch
i think the second viewing really
elevated it for me when i had more of an
idea of what i was in for i think a lot
of people will take different things
from it
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
and theories on the film below
it's really well acted and had the
pacing being a lot tighter
i think it would be getting more
favorable reviews however the heart is
definitely there
and now i guess the twist in the first
10 minutes that doesn't mean that the
journey wasn't worth taking
the midnight sky is something i think
people should check out and make up
their own minds on
and it gets a 7 out of 10. now don't
forget that on the 30th of december
we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
sweet home on netflix which will be
linked on screen right now
we go over the entire season and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
watch the korean horror
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i don't speak to you
before
friday have a merry christmas and all
the best for the new year
take care peace
love you